the professional excitable beautiful
I know
I usually say I know why you're excited
this week I'm going to tell you why I'm
excited
Mitt Romney tonight is fighting Evander
Holyfield gee I'm not making this up
you've heard this right yes that Mitt
Romney is fighting a boxing match well
it's a charity boxing match with Evander
Holyfield it's a friendly exhibition to
raise money just like the Mayweather
fight last week friendly Wow Mitt Romney
I'm telling you they asked him why is he
doing this he said I don't know I guess
I just like getting beaten by black guys
but now everybody this week is talking
about one of the worst train wrecks ever
but enough about the Jeb Bush campaign
oh we learned something this week
there's actually no such thing as a
smart Bush they kept saying he was this
part no no oh I think only a bush could
answer a yes or no question two
different ways and be wrong both times
Abby it wasn't that hard either he was
asked knowing what we know now would you
invaded Iraq and he had a different
answer every day first it was damn right
I would absolutely [ __ ] great idea
and the next day it was sorry what I'm
sorry I I misheard or I misinterpret and
then the next day it was well that's
hypothetical like it said what did it
when did a politician ever heads our
hypothetical question and then finally
it was okay my brother's a giant [ __ ]
you happy
every day a different answer which is
how we got his nickname the undecided
and all this was on Fox News where the
anchors are ordered to pre like you I
say I think the Bush family has actually
been in decline since the Patriot
patriarch Prescott Bush he was Jeb and
George's grandfather the first President
Bush's father he was a good guy he was a
senator from Connecticut moderate
one of the first big advocates for
Planned Parenthood if only he had
practiced what he preached
and chef Jeb Bush took his witness about
again today he said get this that it
would be okay if we repealed Obamacare
because soon people will be able to
manage their health using the new Apple
iWatch and I have one let's see if it
works and seriai I think there's
something wrong with my heart okay
I found three theaters playing paul
Blart
no no not called large okay now as for
the Amtrak derailment we still don't
know what caused the train crash or why
Mitch McConnell always looks like he's
just seen one but how's this for
sensitivity hours hours after the crash
House Republicans voted to cut em tracks
budget hey why do Republicans hate
trains this is what seriously
they love everything else from the good
old days swing music and route 66 and
segregation but
so now if you get to work in anything
other than a Buick you're not a real
American
I don't get that I love trains I it's
the only way to travel anymore doesn't
involve a TSA agent slowly tracing the
curve of my inner thigh why do
Republicans hate drink well of course we
know because they're subsidized by taxes
as opposed to the interstate highway
system which is a naturally occurring
geological formation I hope they get to
the bottom of why this train crashed but
I don't know if that's going to happen
because the engineer involved says he is
absolutely no recollection of what
happened so I don't think he's going to
be driving trains in the future but he
has a very bright future as Tom Brady's
ball handler